[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what is up my dudes hi guys
it says it's literally just whispering i
don't know
[Music]
hi everyone what's up
i am live today
uh raising money for pancreatic cancer
um
i hoped to do this stream a lot earlier
today but work didn't stop
uh for all the people in chat
complaining about how late i stream um
it's not by choice uh yeah you know
having a demanding job means uh often i
am working up until i can stream it is
not uh
not a thing i wanted to do but
point being we're raising money for
pancreatic cancer the link should be in
the description
it's in the like panel section on twitch
should be directly in the description on
youtube
um but i will also just link it here
boom why is my chat not auto scrolling
that's a bit annoying
[Music]
i don't know why it's not um it is
11 p.m here right now it's not that late
for me uh not a big deal
um people always comment on me streaming
late on weekends and i'm like what are
you
what you going about 10 pm on a friday
why are you doing that you know what i'm
saying
i don't know why the messages won't
scroll that's going to cause problems
for us
uh but yeah to give you guys some info
about like why pancreatic cancer is
specifically
um research that needs to be funded if
you didn't know that's
alan rickman was killed by pancreatic
cancer so was steve jobs so was patrick
swayze so was sally ride who was the
first woman in space
um it's basically considered a death
sentence if you get it because
you have less of a chance of surviving
having pancreatic cancer
than you have of surviving a lethal
injection
so you are more likely statistically to
survive a
lethal injection than pancreatic cancer
uh it has an eight percent survival rate
which is the lowest of every kind of
cancer
and sadly is also really underfunded um
it sucks that it's the one with the
lowest survival rate and
also the least funding um
so i'm doing this stream for pink one
uh playing fable anniversary i was gonna
do full guys they took a
yeah why won't you just scroll chat why
won't you scroll uh i did
i did a poll on twitter for what game
people wanted me to play i was gonna do
fall guys if i could get a good group of
people together because i don't want to
do it by myself because i am not
very competitive um so like because i
don't care if i win
i don't know that you guys would just
find it that interesting i care about
seeing my
friends win you didn't say that you have
an eight percent
chance of surviving execution you have
over an eight percent chance of
surviving a lethal injection
a different thing uh does covert have
more funds what do you mean by that um
they do have a response to covert with
the specific call right now
um though too
[Music]
let me find that that messaging um there
is a reason that you should donate to
this during covet it is part of their
campaign i can find it probably
it's a bit annoying when my stream's set
up but there is a specific reason that
uh
they were like we know clove it's
happening
but we still need a lot of help oh thank
you rahul coley for that 150
donation oh thank you uh
celtic chief twenty dollars annie with
five dollars solaris with ten dollars
res 99.5 anonymous with 20 and anonymous
with five also and also we got a
donation from someone way earlier in the
stream the cow who
said he wouldn't make it but is awesome
okay i need to figure out
why my chat won't load because otherwise
i'm gonna have to lean forward and like
scroll it on my mouse every now and then
it's super weird
but uh play watch listen is live i don't
know why that's happening but yeah so
i'm doing fable anniversary
i did actually stream this on twitch the
other day but i'm restarting it because
my chat at that point in time mentioned
that it is on xbox game pass
by default i tend to play everything on
pc um
but it wasn't on the pc version of game
pass it is on the xbox
version of game pass so i'm currently
playing this on console i need to set my
delays up
good reminder um
it's gonna be a webcam filters a plus
a render delay 500 milliseconds that's
what you have to do when you scream
stream from a console so right now it's
gonna look like my mouth is out of sync
then we delay my microphone also in
advanced audio properties
microphone is also delayed by 500
milliseconds
beautiful um yeah i swapped over to xbox
because it's only on steam on pc
and i want the achievements and also i
play this game
all the time usually on my birthday
every year so you know
who cares not an issue for me oh i'm not
playing fable4 i didn't think about what
the headline said that's a good point
i should have thought about that thank
you senior busy men also yeah i will um
uh take any of the donations that go
through superchat and put them on um
uh the charity as well so that does take
a long time though it's like a month
oh this isn't a this isn't a haircut
it's just really hot
didn't get my hair cut uh this is my
favorite fable
and one of my favorite games of all time
literally in my top five i absolutely
love this game
so let's [ __ ] do it shall we oh it
even has my old avatar
oh look at her okay
why are you not loading chat i guess i
can
refresh it can i load a game i don't
have any right i should that sucks i
didn't it means i didn't transfer my
save from my 360 which is such a bummer
stupid me
[Music]
um this game when it first came out had
major performance issues as well but
uh from what i played the other day it
seemed fine so maybe it'll be all right
maybe it won't break you know we love we
love a functional video game holy [ __ ]
chat why won't you scroll
well it wasn't in the top five null dogs
cam of my
list of playstation 4 and xbox one games
because it came out
on the original xbox pro i do love the
arena in this game it's like the only
game where i like
the forest of albion small
unchanged by time and untouched by the
sword
you guys can still hear it here lived a
boy and his family
a boy dreaming of greatness
sometimes he imagined himself as a noble
knight or
a powerful wizard
and other times he dreamt he'd be an
evil warrior
but in all his dreams and now we've got
a reset for some reason he should be
about there
perfect we fixed it it was just coming
through my monitor for no reason
i don't know why it did that i would
have assumed that because i had it
plugged into my controller it didn't
decided to daydreaming again were you
just like your mother
mind always won scrolling isn't your
fault
she's out playing by the barrows she's
out playing by the barrow fields gate
you're a birthday present yet don't tell
me you've forgotten a ghetto one
well you gotta get your sister birthday
present man that's what i'm saying
that's what i'm saying
i'll give you a gold piece for each good
deed you do around oakville
that should be enough what's played for
good or evil i think i might let people
who donate decide that
stay out of trouble yeah i feel like if
you want to if you guys donate
as much as you like you can be a dollar
um whatever the limit is i don't know
um you can choose what my next choice is
right so like there are already a bunch
of good or evil choices in the very
beginning of this
um in this like tutorial mission i
[ __ ] love this game
such a good game
um yeah you can say if you want you want
good or evil and i'll do whatever it is
that you prefer
i want you to know that i don't like
playing evil in video games
i don't know if you know this about me
but i would consider myself to be
i'm not lawful good because i don't
respect a lot of the law
but i am like aggressively
moral so i don't even like being bad at
video games
uh thank you taco cub anonymous bear
claw ben the frosted snowflake and
ian for also donating you know what
devin diabetes who just donated 20
my dude i will kick a chicken for you
you [ __ ] got it dude you [ __ ] god
all right let's just
zoom out and see if that fixes my stupid
chat issues
is it working
seems to be working okay is it chaotic
good is that what i'm thinking of
would chaotic good be what i would be in
this situation
lawful is relative and you are lawful
good if you respect what you define the
laws that dictate your actions to be
i guess i should read into it further um
oh man thank you so much uh toll for
nothing he said i lost an uncle
to this [ __ ] anything i can do to help
the suffering of others i'm willing to
do
uh it yeah it's it's a crazy crazy
underfunded cancer
um
the stats like i was reading into this
before like deciding to do this this
weekend
um because i've done so many charity
streams and
i could do them constantly but i don't
want to bombard people either
uh but eight percent
it's it's nuts i'm so sorry that
happened but thank you for your donation
i appreciate it
um all right so we have one request for
the first choice to be evil from taylor
and then one to kick a chicken
ruff if i can kick this chicken right
here
hang on hang on i gotta get again how do
i target the chicken do i have to be an
adult to kick the chicken i don't right
there it is get rekt scrub
perfect video game channel uh this [ __ ]
can be looking for rosie
no we don't want to fight her we just
want to talk to her i've lost my bear
i left her and i can't remember where
stupid idiot the stuffing is
changing today and i can't find it thank
you ezekiel please
appreciate that thank you she's a lovely
little furry bear
with a blue patch on her back
[Music]
okay and then sarah this is very
conflicting sarah just did five dollars
and said you better be good no evil
behavior please
but somebody already asked i have to do
one evil thing here and then
you can't make statements like that that
are asking for too many things
it's not fair uh is this the dude who's
cheating on his wife
no he's over here
it's this is you know what's the moral
solution here this dude's cheating on
his wife
doing a nice kiss yeah my little pumpkin
come here my little pumpkin
you're so naughty scum
what uh oh i was just um i've never even
met you haven't you
yeah your little pumpkin keep your mouth
shut about this
right my wife's at home with our little
ones and i'm supposed to be working
another one so please be good thank you
tj especially with 20
tell you what if you keep this little
secret i'll give you a gold piece
a piece of [ __ ] so what do i do what do
i do
take his bride would be committing a bad
deed
which i have to say yes because the
first the first one was
oh man okay so we have one evil two
goods and another evil from scooterman
gaming
who's my twitch mod was a mixer mod
rap uh i'm sorry you guys i'm taking the
bribe
taking the break good lad here my advice
to you
don't get tied out of one woman look
after yourself
forget everyone else don't get tied down
to one woman
oh god it's terrible i do monogamy
awful i'm a very big proponent of
monogamy just so you're all aware
i don't know how anyone even has the
energy to date more than one person you
know it doesn't make sense
okay here we go subtitles on for you
guys
odenski's okay so now we got two good
ones i believe
you're so romantic well you wanna i want
to see how good he is with the ladies if
he's getting he's pulling two of them i
love you more than any of the others
oh that's implying that they're in i
really love me
i like her top you know i would wear
that for sure
that's real nice yeah
all right well you guys have great
chemistry have fun bye
who's his wife i think she might be in
the house i actually don't remember
hello anybody home no i guess not okay
uh two good deeds you guys you gotta do
two
good deeds i still haven't found rosie's
stupid whatever
i love this dude's accent and his
mustache trader
i wonder the world buying and selling
wares
especially to find folk like your good
self
i'm gonna have to start making a list
well whatever you said okay so
richie said happy to help and donate to
a great cause thank you
a blue elite said what what very good
very good
scots are definitely good but break the
crates what does that mean
how am i supposed to
definitely good but break the crates
what
okay uh good guy time said cam
will said something them all yes it
sensed it what you said on the donation
will so that could be
love them all it could be kind to them
all
it could be um nice them all
so that's i'm assuming that's what it
means
mike said evil thank you for the twenty
dollars nate said
hope your dad stays healthy and so she's
doing good he's doing good thank you
i appreciate that sarah again
said be completely good during the
trader escort quest is that better okay
okay i appreciate that sarah i can do
that we'll get to that quest too
some little girl and it seems you have
got a question
i love this video it just so happens
that i have a rather nice box of sweets
here
guaranteed to put a smile on any
sister's
uh i can't do it yet brad i ain't got
the cash i ain't got the cash
okay what are we gonna do um i'm
supposed to be good here
oh that happened that fast
what the guards are after me because i
took a man's bride because he's cheating
on his wife
i've heard reports that you've been
doing bad i just accepted some money
from an adult
accessory to improper man and lady
behavior
that sort of behavior is not acceptable
if you were older
you'd be able to find it by the town
[Music]
you need to decide if behaving like that
is worth it
my young friend i'll leave it at that
for now
but think about what i've said thank you
michael
um okay if we go down here we got our
boxes to smash but i'm actually not
gonna do it because
smash them up wouldn't you rather be
smashing things goodness
listen um you know is he a scouser
that's a call of nature
oh i said this the last time i streamed
this but is
anyone rahul are you still here is he
scouse
i'll play it again just stand between
those two stacks and don't move he's not
doing the
sounds but i think he's scouts right
i'll put a good word in for you when i
get put in a good word for you when i
get back
right won't be long is he yeah barely
scouse well that still counts doesn't it
i'm pretty sure he is that's all i'm
saying i'm
pretty sure ah rahul said he is
confirmed ywa
very good all right
the request was to be good at the
barrels in these warehouses
while he's away smash his barrels up and
see what's inside
americans would say you sound australian
you're probably not wrong
unless you're too scared unless you're
just a big blubbing
anyone's ever been a big blobbing girl
it's this guy
come on let's go and break stuff i can't
mate i gotta wait for the timer to go
down
and i gotta write down the [ __ ] order
i have to do [ __ ]
very cool notebook dc phantom
things all right bro hey i wouldn't
prefer to be smashing things
come on there's still time are you just
gonna stand there like a lemon
okay i have another good
and then i have an evil
let me figure it out fine have you
stupid good deed then
all right mate rude okay that was the
evil
that was the good during good
during trader quest excellent
thanks lad you've done me a big favor
doing me a big
favor you [ __ ] love it it's so good
oh thank you dancing apple who said i
have diabetes that means some high risk
of this thank you for ten dollars
and doctor blake for the fifteen dollars
and
frank m man yeah there are a bunch of
you who are talking about losing family
members to pancreatic cancer massive
bummer
uh oh wow i'm nefarious uh i think
topped out rahul for top donator
151 dollars thank you
uh and jamie smith who donated five
dollars
did this just get released no uh uh
azaya this game
this game be old real old fable
anniversary even is like
seven years old maybe i think
i'll let your dad know what a splendid
specimen
not that new
all right we are two dollars i have to
do
another good deed apparently stupid kid
uh i can go to the bully he's around
here somewhere
i think he's just up this way i'll beat
someone up
that's that's what it's about that could
just call me a lemon
are you just gonna stand there like a
lemon
all right bro what's up what's wrong
with you get him off
me please help she goes around the town
beating up anyone smaller than him
rude oh you look strong i am i bet you
could scare me i've been lifting
guns oh you can't see it but i swear
it's good you know
huge you can't you can't see it but wow
that's that bicep's massive
you can't but that's too bad
okay so we want to talk to this kid what
are you doing
i'm just dealing with this breath i'm
just delivering this breath
he was irritating me playing with my
sister
uh that's gonna be rosie no he won't
give it to me
just because i said i'd rip his stupid
outfit oh seems fair mate i told him
if he doesn't do what i say i'm gonna
make his life a miserable
suck sick beanie though oh thank you
henrik
and jay just donated five dollars and
requested eat pies
i will add that to the list of things
eat
pies you say
i'm gonna beat this kid up
i'm sorry i'll leave him alone just
please don't hit me get ready scrub
thank you you stopped doing good yeah
thank you brag about it yeah i'll let
you look after rosie
she'll be safe with you that's rosie we
gotta who's gonna give me a dollar for
this
which one of you kids is gonna give me
the cash that i deserve for beating up
that kid
uh thank you atlas is tired and no pause
all right
yes can you give me a dollar please
thank you so much your eyes are [ __ ]
up come on rosie
let's change your stuff but first
i need a dollar
yeah my dad's just gonna give me the
dollar i guess that's how that works
do good deeds dad give me cash
being a kid was so simple
that girl looks hideous they all sort of
look a bit hideous um to be fair
but we love that about it
[Music]
what suicide squad character am i
excited for in the upcoming movie slash
game
i'm a man of my word so here's the gold
for your good deeds
none of them it's not not really any of
them but if you think that i'll turn up
lined up look
try to keep out of trouble please all
right
well i think you may have enough there
son have you spoken to the i have
yes let me go speak to the trader
so that i can get some chocolates for my
sister
huh yeah
i did get rosie thank you okie
mo from aka your miscellaneous item oh
you're lucky you're not even looking at
me mate there you go thank you quickly
give me three gold pieces now and they
all great
three gold pieces four sweets seems like
oh [ __ ] i'm so sorry i am so sorry i
hope you're okay
that is a massive bummer obviously i
hope uh everyone and your family is
doing all right
um okay
good i love what's up what's up with
this where's that filthy layabout
husband of mine
yeah i wouldn't cheat on her
you know what i'm saying i she seems
like she's a great personality and i
would
never cheat on her
you know just saying with some woman i
don't well that's yeah you're right
i run his house bring up his children
and what do i get in return
nothing if you find him let me know
won't you should i tell her
oh well we did a good deed i have to do
an evil deed so it's known
done if you're right you'll see him
you'll be doing a very good deed to let
me
know you kind of see those titties
though
i don't know what's wrong with me
thank you fool's redemption george
stanley said why do all british voices
in these games sound like jon's
impression of rahul
to be fair this is a british made game
uh these are actual british accents
they're not uh they're not made up
giraffes that have a good stream do lots
of mean things
okay let's add evil it's another one for
evil i'm gonna have to start another
playthrough though
this is gonna be a stream play through
because i feel dirty it's not my
playthrough
i don't like it are we have we hit a
thousand dollars yet
we may be almost there maybe have we
maybe we have
i can't tell because it's the my font is
too small
not quite not quite we'll get there
um okay
i'm sorry if i woke you up last night it
was another of those dreams
i was standing in this field when
something happened
but i can't remember what never mind
that though
uh fridge it's i'm playing this on xbox
one it should say in the title maybe i
didn't do it
give the chocolate see my sister i knew
you were going to bring me chocolates
it's just fable five confirmed or were
you tripping fable four was confirmed i
wouldn't count it as [ __ ]
for my party any minute now thank you
kelby thank you for the fifty dollars i
appreciate that
all right love what do i have to walk
away for this to trigger is that what
you're telling me
there we go wait there's something would
have been nice if you could have known
this sooner
you've been real helpful
it's really happening they're here
you've got to hide
[Applause]
useless kid
he looks so dumb also you hear that song
in this game a lot
thank you a red elite it ain't much but
it's honest thought very nice
very nice bandits wielding torches and
steel oh josh pitt also said evil damn
it
i hate you all why are you making me do
this i don't feel good about it
don't feel good about it blood red
flames lit the night
as the villagers screamed and yeah fable
one's a really good game
why do the faces look so weird i don't
know games like
12 years old pretty old
then the raiders reached the last house
where the boy and his family lived it
was them
they had slaughtered so many to find
what twist didn't see that coming
the father fought to protect his kin but
he was no warrior
and fell mortally wounded alright
dad miss you fam the bandits rip the
house apart but could not
find them because he was just hiding in
that farm the whole time well thank you
paul
thank you so much his mother and sister
remained silent
and their furious attackers took them
jack of spades yeah that's the bad guy
yeah jack of spades is back
it's jack of plates but yeah from the
nearby woods
the boy watched oh hello adrian taken
away from brisbane
yeah i guess the time zone i'm streaming
in right now is convenient for
australians
he was alone can relate bro
super alone no those feels man
sometimes it do be like that
oh [ __ ] everyone's dead
all right well you know i'm just going
to walk out of here casually when
everyone i know has
died um know not upset about it it's
fine you just walk through this
a pass you know
oh there's my hug
that's roof bad idea bad call
shiny silvery i have told them that i
would love to be in the new fable
just to have a cameo but uh seems
unlikely
[Music]
then give me your hand so nasally
it is just giant the kid has bigger
hands than maize does
hands hello watson
maze you're fake bro it's true he is
he is fake bro
hmm i thought you'd have a stronger
stomach than i mean he is rude from the
start at least it's not surprising that
he turns
out to be a [ __ ] he's always kind of
a [ __ ] it's not me you want to fight
you might not realize it thank you saved
your life
whoa atomic atlas thank you for 100
donation thank you so much
i think that pushes over to a thousand
you'd be as dead as the rest of them it
did
thank you so much i appreciate it
my name is mays and i'm the head of the
guild of heroes it has
you must have heard of it i love it
you'll find nowhere safer in all of
albion
nor a better place to call your house
probably correct too and if it's
vengeance you want
you'll need the training only we can
offer
thank you ernesto i'll introduce you oh
man
fable one's way better than fable2 in my
opinion subjective obviously but i think
this game's way better
i don't like any of the other fables
anywhere near as much as i like this one
most wanted feature for number four it
would be combat like
um i always say this combat like
kingdoms of ammo
i have a new student for you put him in
the door i didn't like the combat in two
and three it's just too simple
you don't look much like hero material
to me why is everybody making
tell me i have a weak stomach when
everyone in my [ __ ] family's dead
in the whole town and then this dude
tells me to look like a hero i'm a
literal child
you heathens you'll be sharing this room
with whisper
one of our brightest young peoples
whisper she's playing in the woods right
now
but you'll meet her in the morning
brilliant for now you should get some
stuff
like the guild seal tattooed on his head
or did magic do that to him did he get
that tattooed on his forehead
do you have any potions or food try to
get your combat multiplier
even higher
thank you gun snake i agree fable one
best time it's time to wake up
you must be my roommate all right
everyone's so mean this is what they say
when they mean british people i mean
i've been here forever they just can't
help it not that she's british
or any of them are really albion doesn't
exist you know you talk in your sleep
but uh sounded like a bad nightmare
british people wrote it not the first
week they just can't help but be me some
don't even last that long
you won't either if you don't get moving
the guild master is waiting for us in
the map room
you received a new quest thank you for
the 20
kyle t um
i sleeped in i sleeped in there's a
sentence i just said yeah for anyone
just joining us we're raising money
for uh pancreatic cancer research right
now looks like the guild master got
tired
it has the lowest survival rate of all
cancers eight percent
uh it's the cancer that killed alan
rickman and steve jobs and patrick
swayze
uh to name a few people um and
it also gets the least funding for
research while having
the lowest survival rate so yeah they
say pancreatic cancer is the cancer
that makes you wish you had a different
kind of cancer um so we're trying to
raise money
for research for pancreatic cancer uh
links to donate should be in the
description hopefully
and uh playing fable one
because i took a poll on twitter where i
suggested a few games
fall guys did win but i couldn't get
people to play it with me
well not four people at least and um
yeah i don't think that i'm very
interesting playing uh
uh can i pick that up sook a cooking
apple uh when i play competitive games
by myself because i don't care about
winning i care about my friends winning
i'm gonna leave people don't care about
me winning your
pillow i see all right lad it's time to
see if you've any potential all this
roasting
about the kid being tired really makes
me feel attacked it's like they wrote it
for me
how did they know as hard as you can
just uh thank you anonymous 20 mcphalia
for 28 who said evil fabled eats the
good deed stream
okay we're adding another evil to the
list when the option
arises that's another evil oh thank you
roger and scorpio echo who just donated
a hundred dollars
thank you so much
uh okay let's do it
smack a [ __ ] up i'm not making much of
an impact there okay
brits man with this oh yeah i didn't get
a haircut it's just tied up
um i will pretty much never cut my hair
short
i don't think i would literally ever do
it unless i needed to for like the
health of my hair but otherwise
yeah this game does have a really long
tutorial but i like the way it does the
tutorial
that's neat i'm interested when you
destroy an enemy
like this dummy it drops an experience
did you ever pull the sword out of the
rock because i couldn't when i was
little
yes a tucson pancake to pull the sword
out of the rock in this game
that you collect i think you have to
have a certain amount of
good morality pick it up
i believe you pick up experience orbs
with
rt love it
it's a misleading title oh again yeah
i didn't think about it when i wrote i
just wrote fable for charity i wasn't
trying to mislead anyone let me update
it
i didn't like think that people would
think that i was playing fable4
me um it wasn't it definitely isn't
intentionally like click bait or
whatever i just didn't
i didn't think about it let me update it
to say f o r how do i do that where do i
how to do i have to do it on my pc
hey latest episode of play watch listen
it's live everybody that's exciting
it took a long [ __ ] time to edit okay
here we go fable f-o-r
charity so people don't get upset
or charity
done there you go
misleading titles are acceptable it's
charity stream that's fair you know i
kind of agree with you if you're
misleading people for
to raise money for cancer research stuff
so bad
but that said it wasn't intentional at
all uh [ __ ] fracas said thanks for
running this fundraiser and playing the
best game hey man
anytime anytime
thanks for being here
okay let's [ __ ] up some beetles
this way
[Music]
i like to think that everyone in this
game is just high which is great because
you can get high
no you can get other people high in this
game man the first fable is not a kids
game
like there's a brothel what happened
thank you for the 10 slamming and
anonymous and andy thank you guys
i have a feeling peter mullen you would
make us all upset with his promises
hey he's an ambitious dude it's like a
kojima situation with peter molina i
think well like
you know he's trying to do the thing
doesn't mean he can necessarily do it
but he trying i don't think he's he's uh
he doesn't realize that let's get pulled
up
that's the sound isn't it that's quite
quite a droning
pungent on the ears or whatever [ __ ] you
dude
and then they scream when they die
give me all your experience
[ __ ] dundum i got 21 for that
dude i kill a lot of bugs wow i get
catched up every time i kill bugs
thank you alex and thank you lachlan
appreciate it
uh farrell said my grandfather passed a
year ago from prostate cancer and i wish
there was more he could have done other
than chemo
ain't that the truth uh anything to
further cancer research also at least
two good deeds to keep allana sane i
appreciate you
thank you for that so that's good and
good you're allowed to make
multiple good requests i will not allow
multiple evil requests i don't make the
rules
okay that's just the way it works i'm
not playing fable for
okay i'm sorry that it looked like it
said that
thank you harrison
why would rahul be an awesome cheeky
voice for faye before why can't i be the
cheeky voice in fable
i bet he hasn't even played fable fake
gaming he's playing
playing fifa or whatever you know it's
probably going to be you've earned
yourself some pocket money for that
if you want more gold i'm sure the
servants could use your health
oh call of duty fifa or early night
ridiculous
you've won the guild mastering people
for uh do i want to leave my childhood
behind yeah i do i super do
yeah the guild was now the boy's life
the memory of the oaks hey we did hit
1.5 thank you thank you jerry who also
said good deeds
and thank you and john training who said
i also vote for good deeds since albion
much like our world needs more heroes
very poetic that's gonna be two months
filled with grueling exercises exercise
study
in the library honestly that's what i
feel like my life is like right finally
he was ready to become a guild
apprentice just
oh thank you turning home real training
[Laughter]
okay we gotta watch fable four
get out of
i don't know how they knew how did they
know oh thank you ravioli
they said fable looked evil i mean it is
again i don't really think this is that
much of a kids game
you know what i'm saying i just don't
know that it's
that childish really
oh scouse accents hard harrison i have
um
[Music]
i have spoken to the head of playground
about voicing for some of their games
before um
but yeah i feel like that one's probably
not gonna happen
based on the lack of response like it's
not like i haven't i have spoken to them
about it in person but like the fact
that it hasn't uh come up again but
maybe it could be way far
further in the future but i never want
to push anyone too much because i have
no way of saying that i am talented at
it i just
want to be involved in video games as
much as possible
oh andy did also say good deeds you're
right you couldn't put that that's
another good
way we'll begin training with real
weapons now
get used to the weight good during
trader eat pies evil evil evil good good
good good
good i can't do any of this [ __ ]
while in this point of the game sadly
but um we'll get there
come on then let's see what you've got
farmville all right mate
oh yeah i always forget to have to equip
it which is sort of dumb
do you recommend avengers alana i don't
know man if i don't know you
i can't tell you it's dangerous i don't
know what uh what kind of games you like
so i can't recommend anything to you
frankly
uh this is absolutely not the first time
that i have played this it's one of my
favorite games ever i've finished this
game
not all blows can be blocked i want to
say more than i finished any other game
but it actually it could be halo one
all right the block is it's so funny
it's just like you just hold wine
at the time i was like well blocking
mechanic
but then we out here playing sakura in
that i can't stop you every time all i
have to do is hold y
thank you john i'll hit you next time
oh you're fine no you didn't come across
like you were massively criticizing it
or anything
well done now let's see if you can
combine attack
and defense
ah hello hello thunder check on your
sister's progress have you ever
you could do all the silver keys i won
on this playthrough
because again if we're being evil it's
not my playthrough but usually i
do get all the silver keys has great
potential
enough to keep up with my whisper thank
you austinite for the two hundred
dollars
what oh my god thank you they're just
working on uh g
five dollars and emma who said do some
good things in the game good deeds for a
good cause
excellent more this will be a no good
just like your final melee test i'm
loving it
oh [ __ ] i pressed the wrong button not
off to a great start
yeah sure
shame you couldn't see me fight in the
arena you might have learned a thing or
two
keep training uh is donations on stream
separate from ones in chat
yes i will donate the ones in chat but
it will take me a month
um so i would highly recommend donating
for the donation link instead
speaking of which meet me as i make
thank you
um
i agree dragon's dogma is a really good
underrated rpg
i strongly agree well uh thank you
michael
mchale rather i was about to be cheeky
and donate 19 for the 50 dollars i
already threw in but that is just
challenged to 20 dollars it is
oh yeah you did make it thank you god
damn it chip
another evil you're technically uh
technically right sorry dancing gap will
give five dollars and said i have a
feeling you're going to end up playing a
chaotic neutral character you're
absolutely right
that is going to happen um we want to
continue
then meet me by the archery range to
continue your training brilliant
i find it so funny that everyone freezes
in the background in this game
um i want to go talk to
the dudes who are doing the race
these boys because i'm pretty sure i can
do this
we're discussing whether i'm the fastest
apprentice in this game are you the
fastest apprentice and is guild
i ran to the demon door all right bro
i'll [ __ ] beat that then yeah let's
do it right then
i did it in 50 seconds it was pretty
pretty speedy or that pear pear hedge
gonna slow me down
come on
i did do this the other day i'm pretty
sure at this age but i actually don't
remember exactly what did i do when i
was an adult
across this cross this cross this and
then run back
oh heck oh no i might have just failed
oh it's too slow
that other guy adam said evil all day
let's get them horns all right
i'm going to fail you sons of [ __ ]
[ __ ] no
no no
damn it let me add
another evil arrogance that's for sure
george also said evil god damn it we got
three evils in a row
killing me thank you reister no you're
not
vogel said as a brit i confirm we are
horrible people mark me down for evil
son of a [ __ ]
no you're not this is so many evils all
right i'm gonna do this race again yes i
am you again
you didn't do too well okay okay okay
okay let's go
was i not sprinting that last time is
that why i screwed it up did i forget to
hit sprint
i don't think i did
we just got to try to not clip on
everything ever because the game is
really [ __ ] old
it's not my fault it's not my fault okay
that's good feeling good about this i
probably went further than i needed to
[ __ ]
again ah i think we're gonna be okay
this
time i'm feeling it that rock didn't
screw me up for as long
there are like slightly less people
hanging out around here
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's really hard to hold
down b and also control the camera at
the same time
oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my
gosh oh my gosh
that's amazing how did you do it i lost
my bet
thank you thank you aditya
and also andy me and the wife have a
rule she can donate for animals and i
can donate for cancer research so here's
some more she votes for good deeds
i will add a good i like that rule
very nice okay i'm just real speedy bro
i'm sure it's like a speedy
so this was it don't worry about it
okay i'm gonna go do some archery oh
thank you zack
oh andre also said good this list of
things is getting really long
um is the issue that's one two three
four five six seven evils and one two
three
four five six seven eight goods it's not
going to be that hard when we get to the
open world but right now there's like
nothing i could do let's continue our
training with the bow
am i gonna do all the demon doors on
this playthrough no i'm
not going to continue this place ruby on
this stream
and put some effort into it the longer
you pull back your bow string the more
damage i agree nikolai
but make sure you stay so cartoonish and
you love it yeah well
i just like being good you know
thank you taco cup be a good person when
next available and give kindness to
someone in the game they're not real
but i appreciate what you said there i
appreciate it that's another one for
good
oh it's hot in here oh my god
all right let's [ __ ] as an x fire the
pattern
file the hour pull back the string the
more powerful your shot will be
you need more muscle behind i actually
didn't do that on purpose so don't sass
me killed master
well done you hit all the targets
unfortunately most foes don't stand
still
so let's see how you fare against moving
targets
you have a minute to score as many
points let's go this setup is actually
really cute it is worth one i would like
to learn archery the middle one is worth
three
on the one there a reason why you
decided to donate to pan can rather than
something else
uh pancan reached out to me they asked
me to do the stream
that's damaged but you have to balance
power
i was like sure i'm happy to raise money
for cancer research see what you can do
let's do it
obviously it's way less than i do for my
other bigger streams but yeah
um no it is five minutes past midnight
pacific time but again
man it's a weekend it's a friday night i
don't know why people always freak out
about the time what are you
are you gamers isn't it normal for
gamers to be up late on a weekend
playing video games
right it's like my whole life
ah thank you scorpion favorite one kept
travel hang on i want to read what you
said here
everyone kept travel and exploration
simple so you maintain your connection
to the story as the game gets more open
while they just connect you with travel
time
bottom sets and it's my mass effect 3 i
don't agree that that's
that's the strength of fable one
um come on yeah all right stop [ __ ]
sassing me
good shooting i'm gonna go for the back
one
i did this the other day that no
you gotta get him like right when he
bounces so like [ __ ]
maybe nope it's like a timing that i had
to like re-teach myself
too late i am mild
i could get the one in the front there
should i miss him too are you serious
ah devastating
that [ __ ] oh thank you for the raid it
was from alfredo
is that who you're saying by freda you
mean alfreda hey
thank you alfredo what was he playing do
you guys have been seeing him play fall
guys lately
this is terrible because none of this is
good but i don't think i get rewards
from it
when i'm a kid anyway right uh as if i
didn't get that one
[ __ ] he was playing four guys we should
play it sometime alfredo that would be
that would be wonderful
good stuff um
i don't get anything from finishing it
twice as a kid so i don't care
okay rodney bad beauty asked for another
good
deed for some good on our list
um so did mustafa
twenty one dollars love an interesting
amount of money
can you romance and bang a granny in
this game if not then just do some other
good deed
no i think you can only romance and bang
like middle-aged women jeff i believe
i'm devastated to tell you that i know
it's a huge bummer but um so other good
deed it is
this is a long messy list
we did hit 2k thank you guys so much
thank you for anyone who's just joining
us we are raising money
for pancreatic cancer research if you
didn't know
pancreatic cancer is what killed alan
rickman it's what killed steve jobs it's
what killed patrick swayze
it's also what killed sally wright who
if you didn't know is the first woman to
go to space thus
sort of a hero of mine uh it's
considered a death sentence because
and this is a fact you have a better
chance of surviving
lethal injection than you have of
surviving pancreatic cancer
which is eight percent you are more
likely to survive a lethal injection
than you are to survive having
pancreatic cancer which has the lowest
survival rate of any cancer
um and it is often considered like the
forgotten cancer because it raises the
least amount of money
and generally there are like so few
weeks
after you're diagnosed that you were
given to live it's absolutely brutal
so a link to donate on twitch i can have
a mod
put in chat hopefully but um i put it in
i don't know the panels area i don't
understand the twitch ui
and it's also just in the description on
my uh
my youtube there there we go if you
would like to donate
uh thank you to inky to riandi lore and
to manky
oh anonymous just beat out the top
donation with a 201
donation very nice uh
i appreciate it you guys yeah all this
money is going to pan can
use a um foundation trying to raise
money for pancreatic cancer research
thank you four dog i appreciate that
we're playing fable anniversary
it's one of my favorite games ever um
and i'm letting
people who are donating to me to said
island by the charity the island by the
waterfalls
the island by the oh that's right it's
will training um
yeah i'm letting people who donate
choose my actions
it's i do have to be older right or is
this the right age do i want to do this
again
i don't i don't remember right this
melee let's just do it anyway shall we
yeah grade me bro right
let's get whispering i have a special
prize for you if you manage an 8 plus
let's go hack her up
oh [ __ ] that's not ideal
nope wrong button damn it i don't know
why i keep pressing all b to flock but
it's not good and i don't want to do it
mate
no it's that and then it's that
no no no no no how have i already
forgotten the block controls
this none of this is good block is not
uh is uh uh because lb is pull out that
that's gonna be i don't know let's just
speed the [ __ ] out of her and do it
again you can stop now i've forgotten
that's sword working you can't do
anything with a b we can't do anything
with the beat i've got a nice sword for
you oh thank you
fib dora who also said good deed please
and timey swells thank you
uh it's another good one that's another
good one
uh yeah adnan this is also on pc i
actually um
block is why thank you guys i genuinely
forgot um
i did actually stream this on pc pretty
recently okay
all right all right uh i streamed it
recently on
steam because it's not on xbox gameplay
um also on gamepods for xbox and i was
like oh is that [ __ ] free
i'm gonna get the achievements on xbox
rather than getting them
on steam because i actually do have the
disc version
as well um so i guess i could also just
literally put that
in my console i've got several options
for how i own this game now which is a
lot of ways
i just [ __ ] pressed it wrong again
why do i keep pressing rb what have i
played recently that's making me do that
[ __ ] did bad again all right
you can stop now we're gonna do it again
almost perfect don't i have to get an a
plus
i've got a nice sword for you if i can i
can't i just have to pay attention to
what i'm doing
right let's get i keep pressing rb i
really don't know what game i've been
playing that's making me do that
i did it immediately again is it go
sushima
i know sakura does that
why am i instinctively pressing rb for
block oh [ __ ]
no that one wasn't even fair
i did it again i'm doing it right now
holy [ __ ] it's
it's l1 okay so it's something that's on
our it's
something making me do it something can
we do it
no alana not again you're not pressing
it again stop pressing i'll be
different video game all right i think
that one probably worked no he would
have said it was fantastic
that's an a if you just press the right
button
if you can get an a i swear to god it's
alana it's y
it's not whatever [ __ ] you've been
playing that is zombie it's y
block is why
uh yeah i'm using an xbox controller
because i'm playing on xbox
we'll do it this time you guys and we'll
do it this time
well i haven't been playing hellblade
it's not that
all right this is the one i haven't
screwed it up even one time
all right you can stop now that was very
impressive whisper should be a [ __ ] she
should
scrub means i can award you a new weapon
you're a wizard hero very nice
all right uh
i got a cool new sword but i think that
i actually did pass on the archery one
which is a problem because i thought
that that was when i become an
it's funny because i know someone called
will powers like
personally all right oh
just keep my hair up it's just you're
just so hot
okay pull and hold rt to access your
will powers
available powers will be displayed in
the bottom right of the screen
i only have this [ __ ] right now oh
wait it's rt good
fantastic see how many you can hit in
hot all right bro
cool cool cool oh it's lt to target pull
will pause over there
oh i have to hit him for longer i'm
sorry demon door i didn't mean to attack
you
i think we got this i think we're going
to do just fine this one's not that hard
i'm sorry the targeting is terrible i'm
not trying to was fine
it was fine excellent use of magic
well thank you
what else are you gonna say um continue
very good lad
in my honest opinion when do i think
sony will reveal the price for
playstation 5.
i believe this is about to go into the
guild woods if you wish to join
the thing about all these conversations
about prices and release dates
is and i'm not like there's no way to
say this politely every time it comes up
on a podcast that i do
i feel like you can hear me sigh
i don't care
i get why other people care but as a
human who no matter what
is always going to buy the xbox series x
and the playstation 5 on launch
i don't care when they come out or when
they announce when they're coming out
personally i just
like the conversation just keeps coming
up and i'm like i just want to know what
games i'm going to play in the first
year
and when the games are coming out you
keep asking me like
when do you think the guy you did for
release date of the price and i'm always
just like okay i'll give you an answer
but [ __ ] me i don't care
i'm sorry that's the truth i just
i gotta get my hair up higher gosh dang
um yeah i don't know if that's just me i
don't know i'm sure other people feel
that way right like i would way just
prefer to know what games i'm gonna be
playing
um other than like the small amount of
launch titles that we have
okay what else have we got here read
some more donations
uh we got timey spells i didn't already
read that number anonymous
fire keeper andy bendy that's another
good
i don't know that i'm gonna get through
all these just for the record for people
who are donating for a request for good
but i will
i will weigh it up uh son of ether
adam 75 thank you shane andy who said
would you be willing to do a stream for
matt peak's old boy scout council whose
camp
cut his scout reservation is getting
down in santa cruz mountain fires
um i think maybe having matt reach out
to me about that would be okay
um you can reach out to him and have him
reach out to me
i'm definitely not against it grim pixel
22. jack sullen we're over halfway now
right we are
it's also on 2769.
nice that's what's up you'll love to see
it
um okay i need to just change my hat
because now it's hurting me so
again now you guys are talking about
console prices
obviously tremendous tremendous position
of privilege but even when i
like you know didn't work in the
industry i still saved up for ages to
buy all my consoles and
i just don't care you know
it's just not a not a big deal to me
okay tie my goddamn
hair up that worked there's a fun fact
about
uh tying your hair up when it's really
long it looks so messy
too much hair um it can hurt it'll like
pinch the top of your head if you tie it
up the wrong way which is i guess
there's a thing that i did oh fire keep
it tc it's tough donation i don't think
everybody saw that
um i thought they donated about 250
thank you so much
one from toby one man army not
uh jack van sala said pancreas correct
pancreas you're right yeah my messy bun
game is the most strong because again
it's just too [ __ ] hot so
we're doing stupid [ __ ] with my hair
right now
and i'm trying not to accidentally tie
my microphone into my hair because
i can't detach the microphone from this
uh this headset
what is this ah
friend sent me that psn so we can play
full guys uh
do i want to play with whisper let's
play let's play well yeah i'll be in the
map room when you're ready to come hey
yeah yeah
you are hyped for spider-man cyberpunk
assassin's creed and batman honestly
um yeah the two games left this year
that i'm mad height to battle miles
morales and cyberpunk for sure
for sure for sure for sure
is there anyone else around here that
has a quest that i can talk to i know i
oh no no the archery guy's there we can
do it
let's do it you really i sure
did she got [ __ ] archery
yeah and if you get an a plus you've got
one minute
when you fire your first shark uh thank
you joven
and thank you go skill oh wow thank you
for the hundred dollars
am i excited all for the rock steady
reveal tomorrow i am
and let me tell you um laser who asked
that question
i've had such a busy work week this week
like
so i mean i started streaming at 11
because i was working from
9am to 10pm right like literally
that was my workday and i didn't get i
didn't get a lunch break i didn't get
like oh cool we got an hour off
that was that was my [ __ ] work day
this week has been
so basically like that every day where
like i haven't had any time
to do anything but work um so tomorrow i
was like
i'm gonna sleep for a really long time
i'm asleep in
i don't have to do anything i told bruce
i would stream with him at night but
otherwise
i gotta do [ __ ] and then i saw that the
rocksteady thing was at 10
30 and i was like oh
do i want to wake up for the record of
sleeping for me is like
1 2 p.m just so you guys don't that's
that chronic fatigue life
i can sleep for 15 hours um
but then i don't know i i really don't
know we'll see how i feel
when i go to sleep like if i'm exhausted
i won't wake up for it but if i do i
will
but we'll see
do you work from home how do you not
take a lunch break i don't have time
like i literally like i don't have an
hour to eat um so today
so that i had time to eat like for the
record my schedule was
meeting inside gaming um
i did a stream for a company called van
uh and then i had this behind closed
doors thing i can't talk about
and then i went straight to the x cast
and then i went straight to the fun
house streams which was trivia and then
among us and then i went straight to
editing play watch listen
um and then i had two other things that
i had to edit and then i did this it's
like there's no chunk of time to eat so
i made myself a smoothie so because
that's really easy
uh i did have dinner though so i feel
good about that okay
anyway that's enough about me um
that is why i started streaming so late
though let's [ __ ] go
let's get a sick arrow
why does the camera make a noise is it
being run by a
little man on a cloud okay
i'm pretty sure that this is i just
he's doing the thing where it just
starts when i
as if [ __ ]
okay we got one oh i didn't even mean to
let that go
too late
it's like there [ __ ]
it's just not that easy that's what we
love to see there
okay good good good
too late damn it damn it damn it damn it
it's so funny because this is the
hardest the archery in this game
literally ever is
oh i could hit him back there okay
you're damn right no one man should have
all that power
too late i think i got it anyway though
you set a new high score i showed it i
showed it never seen any better than
that
you've got an eight plus the guild
master's thank you goldberg
brilliant i could award them this
you are sort of right casey cannon the
straw men do move really poorly when
they're
doing that you're absolutely right oh
that's right people said that last time
to manual aim for it
um it's fine i mean i got it anyway so
you know we good
we're good that was some fancy shooting
okay now we're gonna go play with
whisper
in the woods
let me just walk into the woods and then
it'll happen i'm pretty sure yeah you
can zoom in manually yeah
all right let's do it
did i only hit one thing no i hit little
nest loads of them on top of that
my score was 156 bro you get it did you
hear that
it's coming from over there bandits
which only we could get across that
stage entire body textures
pop in why don't you use your bow or
some of that lightning the guildmaster
taught you
all right i'll heal you if you get hurt
i think
i don't think my lightning goes that far
love like if i'm
oh that's come on
just electrocuting a grown man don't
worry about it don't worry about it
we are running out of will floss though
all right
i'm just gonna you know just keep going
really just keep uh
wheels out yeah we can do this i guess
i'm just sort of smack
ah what is it to manual aim
uh it's not that uh uh
oh okay that and then it's still got a
hold x it's such an archaic
um way to do this but obviously it's
because the game's so old oh my god it's
awful technically we hit him
see that okay okay okay i'm gonna zoom
out because this is the worst
and i'm just gonna go back to using my
will but
later dude
we did it a new fable did get into
facebook recently
wait till the master hears about this
you already does that palpatine powers
you're absolutely right
okay cool uh wait wait did i get all
their xp
excuse me i think i might have i don't
have a
fishing rod yet i can't get whatever is
in the water there
someone who claims to hate the american
spoiled valley girl voice oh i've never
said that casey
no i've never said i hate that voice
i just hate it sometimes when it comes
out of me but i've never said that at
all
no i'm not making fun of people when i
do it it's um i just do a lot of accents
if you are paying attention to this
stream i've done i don't know maybe like
five
like done a few um
thank you bradley i appreciate what you
said there thank you
has anyone my career called you ap
i mean people have called me ap plenty
but not like in my career
but not uh yeah about my career
specifically
yeah i didn't like fable 2 very much
when was i lost in australia chris um
christmas i was lost in australia
christmas i try to go home every year
it's not gonna happen this year by the
sounds of things i'm really gonna try
very hard but uh because of covid
it's extremely difficult
right now oh oh that's right it's just
upstairs
up we go hello
uh i could probably do a palpatine
impression i could do that yeah
do you wish to leave your teenage years
behind and progress under final training
yeah
the boy mastered the skills quickly but
there was
always more to learn there's me for
years the guild was his home
we're about to hit three thousand you
guys what is it
i'm just saying his thoughts always
can't create a cancer
just saying the life he had lost the
family that had been torn from him
yeah yeah again um casey they said well
you said it killed your soul to use that
accent in the game
love video the other day no no no no no
no no i only killed my soul with that
one sentence i said
the accent i don't hate it
it's great good luck
because it's summer there that's what's
up
a friend of mine is greek and he was
able to fly home for a visit since he's
a citizen
would that apply to australia of course
i don't think that any country is ever
going to stop their citizens from going
home that would uh
i mean that that would be you know like
a major international problem
um not letting citizens fly home would
be wondering
how you pass the final test like i think
you'd
[Music]
you you're not allowed to teleport me
it's not fair you're getting better at
this i only did it once
stupid maze
you're getting better at this i'm pretty
great
very good now shoot me with your bow
don't get too i would prefer not to
email someone i'm sorry andy um
i don't know how to organize that but i
would i can have my manager reach out to
that address let's do that
i'm cool with doing that um yeah i'm
happy to help though
and you're it's you're totally not being
inappropriate thank you for the donation
again of course it's totally not not
being uh inappropriate
kmsc 18 also donated 20 dollars
okay very good now shoot me with your
boat don't get too close you know i
thought you'd never ask
me i thought you'd never ask
where's he gone
i guess i can probably just give them
tiny ones yeah make it quick
i would really like to learn archery i
think that would be a fun time
and finally cast lightning are you
trying to make me shock you or something
was like some cake [ __ ] no like what do
you
i did it that's enough that's
quite impressive easier than the
tutorial it kind of is you will find
real battles
rather more fatal than this i imagine
archery is killer on your arms
and you're ready to receive your guild
seal from the guild master
problem is hitting stuff yeah maybe that
does make sense
it does make sense okay
let's go do a real human quest shall we
hmm
sick have i done audrey and vi in the
lab i have
i have well go to bed dude
heck and good said evil is evil lesser
great and middling makes no difference
degree
degree is arbitrary the definition's
blood if i'm to choose between one evil
and another i'd rather not choose it all
also biscuits
and gravy or biscuits and jelly i
remember the first night you came to us
and look at you now amazing
i can tell you're american because the
use of biscuit oh come along
the graduation ceremony will defend me
in the chamber of
biscuit american biscuits are [ __ ]
okay it's not i remember the first time
i
a friend came to see me dj i was driving
um so he got very drunk it was this
place that i used to regularly dj in san
jose um
and i dj that pretty frequently and he
came to see me dj so we drove down from
san francisco all the way to san jose to
dj and
he got smashed and on the way back uh we
went through
a mcdonald's drive-thru and it was the
first time i had heard someone ask for
biscuits and gravy and i was like
i'm sorry what the [ __ ] did you just ask
for
how drunk are you the shadows
because it turns out biscuits in
australia uh
basically like a cookie which actually
mostly we call bickys
my family would call a biscuit of bicky
biscuits in the u.s i still don't really
understand
my ex is from texas and
his mom i think she home made them made
some nice biscuits which is the best
ones i ever had but they're like it's
like a
like a buttery dough like i don't really
know what it is but whatever your use of
biscuit is wrong and you should feel
ashamed of yourself
but also thank you for the ten dollar
donation for pancreatic cancer
not for research
and the jobs thank you
just you can keep saying biscuit and
gravy and i just i just don't like it
that's a really good way of describing
it tremendously it's a savory scone
or scone that's a really good way of
describing new skills
only by doing this regularly will you
advance as a hero
uh pop-tart kitty if you would like to
send something i appreciate that
definitely send it to the fun house
office i don't have a po box or anything
um yeah you can do that for sure um
obviously no one's there very often
right now but there is still security
there getting mail
stuff so let's dip into the light that's
why we're here
biscuit rants you're damn right you're
damn right did we hit 3000 yet you guys
we're only like 16 dollars away i'll
show you
3 000 i'm just saying i'm just putting
it out there
you know we're pretty close dip into the
light
he's gonna keep telling me to step into
the light because this [ __ ] is
really repetitive i wrote this fable
wrap let me see if i can find it
like forever ago step into the light
and i'll show you how to do this
and i'll show you how to do this
step into the light i'll show you how to
do this
where is it uh i think i might have
deleted it
step into the light foundation
fable wrap
i wrote this fable rap in 2011.
um i don't know that i want to read the
whole thing how many this has
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten this has 11 likes
which
like nobody has seen this it's so
funny
uh i'll just read it to you i'll read it
to you like it's pros okay we'll do it
when we hit 3000 you get the fable wrap
six dollars away six dollars away
um and i think the way that i actually
might do it
is that when we hit three thousand you
get verse one
and then when we hit 3500
i'll give you verse two there is a
chorus in here there are four verses
total
and we did it we got three thousand okay
i'll give you verse one and the chorus i
started out in oakville buying chocks
from a trader
it was my sister's birthday gonna give
him to her later
[ __ ] dreamt that bandits would come and
raid us later she became one
that [ __ ] betrayed us i grew up in the
guild [ __ ] a [ __ ] named whisper
but her daddy would be mad [ __ ] yeah
thunder i kissed her
finally finally graduated from the guild
of the zero
[ __ ] up a big wasp now i'm everybody's
hero which you guys will get to see me
do i'ma [ __ ] that big wasp up real soon
um chorus
don't judge me albion i'm the [ __ ]
chicken chaser lock up your daughter
because you know that i could date her
suck my dick ugh veil [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
i'm a [ __ ] slayer come see me in bower
stone yeah don't be a stranger
unless you're a bandit you know i ain't
a hater
i don't know why i don't have the
there's like a
maybe it's in here somewhere there's a
part of this that i remember super
distinctly that is yeah i got some
potions yeah i got some food
my combat multiplier is higher than the
moon but maybe i took that out for some
reason or i'm just missing it
this is probably an early version of
this that i um probably redrafted
this fable wrap okay um
it's a work of art and
you should all be jealous for saying
it's bad
so but i was also drunk and it is also
meant to be bad
um so you can you can have more of that
when we get to 3 500.
can you get a recording at 5 000. i mean
it's so
vulgar too i intentionally was like i'm
gonna make it disgusting
2011 how old was i
18 yeah i would have been 18 when i
wrote it
still on the internet beautiful
beautiful stuff
thank you for three thousand dollars for
the people who donated so that we got
that nice wrap
uh austinite donated another 16
technically they are the one who donated
for the rap and then
our tax override donated five dollars oh
thank you we are raising money from
anyone who
uh for anyone who's just joining us
uh uh uh um
we are raising money for pancreatic
cancer research for anyone who doesn't
know it is the cancer that killed
severus snape well not alan rickman who
played several snape
and steve jobs and patrick swayze uh it
has an eight percent survival rate which
is the lowest of any cancer
but it also gets the least funding of
any cancer uh which is brutal so we're
trying to raise money
basically for uh pancreatic cancer
research
uh it definitely is in need of it so
okay let's keep going
step into the light and i'll show you
how to do excellent
thank you isaac i'm so sorry
definitely intend to keep the podcast
going my dude for sure
thank you whereabouts in oz do i live i
don't
i've lived in the us for five years
um okay what do i want to do here
i'm gonna go with will because that's
the things that i really actually care
about
can't do lightning level two
force push it can be handy but it's not
that handy assassin rush is also pretty
rad i'm gonna do a session rush i reckon
um brilliant and we still have tons left
i need to assassinate level two
okay
i do like speed i can't afford that oh i
only have 251 got it okay i think i can
maybe afford toughness
can i
i can't oh because i had extra toughness
points that's right i forgot how the
level system works
for me to teach you but i will always be
around to offer you
guidance it's a good game august media
is a good game allow me to communicate
with you at all times
you will also notice it flashing oh
what's my podcast it's called play watch
listen new episode just went up i have
given you tonight basic pack of supplies
it'll be enough for a while maybe like
an hour and a half ago i published it
woo hoo we did it
[Music]
yeah i got some potions yeah i got some
food my combat multiplier is higher than
the moon i'm so sad that that
version of it isn't doesn't exist you
know that's all i'm saying
where i i really wrote the [ __ ] out of
that rap
uh okay we want quest this is where our
our requests are gonna come in this is
the first one we have to do it and the
first request is evil
yep you guys are really gonna make me do
this quest the evil way i don't even
know if you can do this quest in an evil
way
but i would like to again bring it up
that it is mentioned
in the opening of my rap okay
finally graduated from the guild of zero
[ __ ] up a big wasp now i'm everybody's
hero
also if you haven't ever heard aussie
hip-hop it's atrocious
and that is what it sounds like on your
map will lead you to your quest
they're like yeah tagging trains
um there's this australian song
that's like quite well known that i
think is just so bad called fig jam
it goes fig jam [ __ ] i'm good just ask
me
it's just it's just so lazy and
australian and all right love calm down
just uh the most it's this way please
aussie [ __ ] you've ever heard i think
aussie hip-hop is uh some of it's okay
but it's just i just think
like the australianness in the wrap just
sounds so odd and it's probably very
strange to other people
all right those are large wasps
this is a pretty lit picnic area too
kill all wasps and pick i didn't boast i
should have boasted
uh hang on nope it's that
i ain't gotta cry about it every animal
ever yeah i think i have to do this
quest good
i sure did love
oh no larger wasp
i'm trying me
kill this very large boss
come on
i don't want to use my bow bro because
i'm trying to get these will points
we can get cool spells oh i have a oh
that's what i want yeah real powers
no it's not
you're making good progress yeah we got
some xp there
we got some xp yeah i'd love to see that
why did that wasp sound like a pig every
enemy in this game sounds like a pig it
is a thing that they do
thank you to good guy goku for the 25
dollars anonymous for 30 dollars
carla for ten dollars patriot four whole
for five dollars he said this game holds
a special place in my heart it got me
through a really rough time
economically somehow it feels
appropriate for me to do something to
get back thank you for the opportunity a
lot i wish i had more to give
never apologize um even a dollar is
helpful you know
literally we're trying to help people
who have cancer if you don't apologize
for donating five dollars
everything is appreciated thank you for
doing it dancing apple
said what game do you think had the best
concept but just the worst execution
remember me um
it had a lot of really good concepts but
it didn't really work
in execution not the worst execution but
or i could say like cube cube's probably
a better pick
a very cool concept that sucked to play
and then had a really bad result
uh aaron the best said if we hit 6k
would you upload the whole rap with a
sick beat behind it also can we get
three more good deeds on the list i can
give you the three more good deeds
for me to upload the whole rap and
actually wrap it
would be a lot more than 6k okay aaron
i don't think you understand how bad for
my career
uploading me rapping um something i
wrote that is bad and terrible
would be i would be mocked forever
so how about 10k
it's uh it would not go down well on the
internet people would hate it
um okay that's three goods that's good
good good
thank you anonymous five dollars and
thank you ten bucks for twenty dollars
if i didn't already say that
it's gonna pivot my career to stardom
it's not true they would absolutely hate
it
they being everyone you become more
renowned you damn right
what do these three dudes look so
intimidating with this musical am i
about to get [ __ ] up
all right bye cool bye everyone oh yeah
this is probably xp down there i love a
goodwill potion
nope i already got it all you've
received a new quest card
nice yes good yes
did this dude do these these really
these dead bodies out here
everybody's dead all right
pick this up thank you
just three lads hanging out on a seat
don't worry about it
the newest rap sensation from australia
inbound that's true but i only do raps
about fable
again i wrote it when drunk at 18 years
old okay
so okay everybody please remember that
maze is looking for yourself
[Music]
i'm gonna have to be mean to a homeless
man look at this filthy pile of rags
it's the same kid from before i don't
feel good about why are you making me do
this why are you making me do this
he really expects people to give him
gold
it's what do you want that's what you
want try belching it's just so
i gotta burp on this [ __ ] homeless
man because that's what the people
donated for you know
okay i'm so sorry dude
oh to have a sword again i've got you
where you
you too just keep so stupid
i love it why don't you belch in his
face see how he
if you really want to improve i guess
this dude might not be homeless
but i think he he talked about it i feel
like that's a thing that happens
i'm not putting up with this there's
plenty of other places to go
it's bullies like you that make
old-timers lives of misery
yeah you loved that did you i didn't
nice one mate if you see anyone you
don't
it's always worth stopping to let them
know i'm sure you'll discover some great
insults
well just doing what they're telling me
to do i don't want to do it some more
hey stinky come back here
thank you sophie i'm so sorry to hear
that but thank you for donating 15
and yo chaotic you donated 50
thank you i appreciate it we had 200
away from
more of the fable wrap so [ __ ]
uh okay guilt let's go
i think wait wait isn't he in bowerstown
yeah we actually don't want to go to the
guilds we want to go down here
which is bowie's done i believe yes
correct yes yes
pretty sure yeah this ain't the guild
gates
let's roll they're gonna make me take my
weapons away or whatever
it's fine
thank you obi-wan shinobi and pretend
this all
i'm sorry i didn't
oh you're new here aren't you
we have some rules around here that you
need to know about
bower stone is a peaceful town
i'll have to confiscate your weapons for
now
how are we doing on chivo's here fam
that's what i want to know we got any
there are shops
inns lots of different people i have to
do that don't i
yeah yeah yeah you're right you're right
i have to do it this way
see i already had achievements from
forever ago
that's the one with the stones that's
like i was like halfway through the game
so i probably won't get any this time
because these are all old as hell it
doesn't say the date but
that would be when i first played it on
360 i think though my choice was
generally always the lost chapters
itself which was backwards compatible
too
oh look at these 360 games backups
doom one bully banjo two of the
achievements for banjo-tooie is so
stupid
enslaved great game great game great
auto sport didn't play much of that
sacred three i played so much of holy
[ __ ] i played so much of that game to
only got 295 gamers called
child delight good stuff mira's edge i
feel like i got a bug achievement on
that for some reason
magic stick of truth that was on [ __ ]
360.
kane and lynch did i finish that i did
there you go soul calibur
4 i actually liked uh
loved the shadow too i liked it some
people didn't like it that much
i was into it obviously [ __ ] right blood
dragon
oh man deadly premonition that's what's
up nine of 12
achievements this game they had 12
achievements
what are the others cool
grand theft auto bastion
forza motorsport we played a very small
amount dead rising
two yeah i didn't finish need for speed
rivals i did play a [ __ ] ton on actually
anyway i don't know why i'm doing this
let's let's just go back to it
all right why not pay the tavern a visit
first
it's a building in front of you just up
the road you
she is the mayor i did beat mira's edge
i think uh mirzad had uh
have a look around an achievement glitch
for me there was something
about like me taking a hard drive to
someone else's house to finish that game
and then when i brought it back
even there was there was some issue with
that that i remember being very
frustrated about but yes i did finish my
research
good day maize it was something to do
with me taking a hard drive
like because you could physically take
them out of the street i remember being
annoyed about it
yes i heard about your encounter with
the wasp queen
most of bowerstone is talking about it
but um you shouldn't let that kind of
thing go to your head
anyway that's not why i called you here
you see there are dark forces gathering
that put your
giant insect to shame tell me
how much do you remember of the night i
took you to the guild
of the raid um i remember you [ __ ]
were rude to me much i wager
thank you favorite thought matt i
thought
you killed your whole family i have
played phantom pain and i did like it
yes but it seems that i'm pretty close
to getting more of the rap
sixty dollars your sister i'm afraid
it's only a rumor
and there's no way to be certain yes my
sister i think you should know
i did already spoil that in the wrap
technically make sure you replace that
basic equipment
i don't think i have very much money
[Music]
i usually like to not actually buy a new
weapon until after the trader quest the
first time you go to oakville because
you can get a pretty sick sword there
this game had really good augments for
swords too
it's a good game all right all right
little girls just so demanding
okay uh this is like her
brother's sick or something like i think
if i beat you they're like here this is
where you want me to go in it
oh whoa is me my son is my
son is poorly boy i'm a poor little boy
we are on a picnic at lookout point when
he found these
these strange mushrooms the witch in
bowerstone key
says we shouldn't worry but she needs
more of the mushrooms before she can
cure it she knows them
i would find them myself but i need to
look after aldi
please could you help us ellie's a cute
name
i'm pretty sure this is what the little
girl tries to get me to go towards the
quest
card all right i beat you you slow his
[ __ ]
[Music]
she's actually pretty cute um all right
i gotta go to the bathroom
i my body is made out of sugar thank you
andrew
i appreciate it and thank you ruby
tuesday how long am i gonna be on
for i mean i wasn't planning to stream
for a super long time
get a rory um
but i would certainly like to hit 5000
but i it's so hot that i'm having
trouble streaming for like more than two
hours right now so
um we'll do what we can but yeah i don't
know i never really know
um i'm gonna go to the bathroom i will
be
nothing is real we're just pixels and
our brains are just
[Music]
numbers
no don't make moon signs we'll all die
my belly button keeps trying to escape
where are you going belly button
what's going on
who's he
your health is low do you have any
potions
who said that you'd have bigger hands
you don't look like no chicken chaser to
me but then again i ain't met one before
oh little sangus where have you been
hiding all this time
the sky is really pretty today
where did the roof go
my body is made out of sugar i hope i
don't fall into a cup of tea
go away headless monkey i don't like
your eyes
nothing is real we're just pixels and
our brains are just
[Music]
numbers
no don't make moon signs we'll all die
my belly button keeps trying to escape
where are you going belly button
your health is low do you have any
potions
who said that
oh little sangus where have you been
hiding all this time
ah there is an important quest card
guild for you
sky is really pretty today where did the
roof go
my body is made out of sugar i hope i
don't fall into a cup of tea
go away headless monkey i don't like
your eyes
nothing is real we're just pixels and
our brains are just
[Music]
numbers
[Music]
no don't make moon signs we'll all die
my belly button keeps trying to escape
where are you going belly bottom
your health is low do you have any
potions
who said that
oh little sangus where have you been
hiding all this time
the sky is really pretty today
where did the roof go
my body is made out of sugar i hope i
don't fall into a cup of tea
oh
go away headless monkey i don't like
your eyes
she was all over me
nothing is real we just pixels and our
brains are just
numbers hi i'm back
i also just washed my face because it's
so goddamn hot
just a nice refreshment stood under the
fan for a bit
this sounds i really left you with these
repetitive noises
oh god um you got some more donations
skoogan said cancer sucks i agree
uh ethan get five dollars digital hound
five dollars anonymous with ninety
dollars thank you
h rubik's cube for fifty dollars mark
dondas
so thank you alana keep up the good work
you know you keep up the good work mark
uh andy said keep up the great work
thank you for everything you do every
day for others oh thank you
adam l you have fifty dollars and i have
to read a new um rap verse
now ready let's pass two
again the the verses are written in
order of what happens in the game
this is technically full of spoilers for
anyone who's just joining us
i wrote this fabled tlc rap while i was
drunk in 2011
and for every 500 i will read you
another first this is verse two
it's a pretty good line actually uh
um protected orchid farm just to get
with the owner
turns out she's a he but i still got a
boner
took the traders through the woods just
to make a bit of cash
got distracted by the bordello and woke
up with a rash
that's it's a problem
uh looking for the archaeologist took me
out to witchwood but when i found
the cockney [ __ ] he told me i was no
good
i killed the i killed the ballerine
legs were opening like demon doors
i'm turning simple knothole glade folk
into massive [ __ ]
i think it rules you can't say yikes
it's supposed to be bad
stop saying yikes okay it's supposed to
be funny
it's not like i was very seriously like
all right let me write this
beautiful rap it's going to be my rap
debut
it's meant to be funny and i think it's
[ __ ] fantastic it still holds up
i will have you know protected orchid
farm just to get with the owner turns
out she's a he but i still got a boner
took the traitors through the woods just
to make a bit of cash got distracted by
the bordello and woke up with a rash
is beautiful work that is
that's what happens next in the game
alright
i did great [ __ ] you um
[Music]
thank you toby again who
donated ten dollars got real deep there
so you guys don't get another
verse we did just hit 3700 you'll get
another verse when we hit
four thousand okay
that's what's up
it's so funny i got oh
yep that's what i was doing as an 18
year old in case you were wondering
writing [ __ ] wraps okay what are we
doing
um i can go in here and get smished oh
no wait
this isn't the no that's someone's house
i want to walk out of that person's
house
i can talk to the witch i think i can
also do the fight club
at night time here
this is where we want to go yes the
bowie stone key
oh thank you jose
i can get smashed in there it's true but
i want
uh i do want to do the fight ring um
let's talk to the witch first
no don't tell
i am a witch you know i read tea leaves
on thursdays
it's brilliant it's a brilliant game
you're not the first fool she sent my
way
find me four blue mushrooms and i can
brew up an antidote
but there's no hurry the stuff won't
kill him
the little tights yeah he's pretty much
high so
that's super cool for him
all right let's do fight club
i wonder if this song is on spotify also
what would this song be called
there is an imposter
fable the lost chapters
there's a playlist oh
wow
this is faber legends though that i'm
listening to right now
it's mostly here though i wonder if this
song is there if it is
i would like to hear it okay excuse me i
would like to fight someone this guy is
one of my favorites because they spliced
their voices up
welcome to the fist fighters welcome to
the fist fighters gang oh we got raid
who would get ready to fight who did the
wait
oh thanks bruce hi welcome everyone
we are doing a stream right now to raise
money
for pancreatic cancer research the
donation link
should be in the description thing if
the geeses would like to help out
uh pancreatic cancer pheromones like the
least funded cancer and also the most
lethal cancer eight percent survival
rate so we're trying to
raise some money for research to help
people who have their cancer and also
when i hit four thousand dollars i will
give you the third verse of a rap that i
wrote
in 2011. it's for people who
like to mash each other's brains yes i
like to do that
and it's a place where we hone our
unarmed armed combat skills let's do it
it's all so
damn good now this guy actually maybe
doesn't have the broken voice there are
some of these fist fighters guys they
clearly steal lines from different bits
of dialogue so they have completely
different accents basing on
the base on the line there is knuckles
look plenty good to me
you up for a bit of a scratch up for a
bit of a scrap if you want to join in
some
you get gold for every
uh real deaths dot sparrow i'm letting
uh
[ __ ] that's not what i wanted this guy
uh i'm letting people who donate to
choose if i go
good or evil
smack him with your fists
peace i love that this is literally just
a group of men who get shirtless and
fight at nighttime
it's their whole thing oh it kicked me
this does get pretty hard though these
get tough
the third one and then it's not punching
you again
good day good day
all right lad that was quick
i feel like i made good work of him
smack him with your fists
[ __ ] him perfect video again
three
go down son thank you thank you
i'll take care of you myself
all right big boy let's [ __ ] roll
yeah well you're not in the ring so you
can't tell me to get in the ring
oh [ __ ]
you get back in the ring right
okay punch punch punch punch
flourish punch no he's gonna
oh that was a good uppercut
later dude that's some knuckle power you
got there
tis the gold i think you these seriously
do get really hot though
like this one is not a good example of
they can [ __ ] you up
i stayed up all night you're damn right
i party
i don't want to do that quest with that
old man as fun as it is i don't want to
do it
i don't want to do it it's too many
steps and the steps are ugly
um i do need to find the blue mushrooms
i don't know entirely where they all are
but
got some donations thank you everyone
for the donation link if you would like
it
there it is in your chats from
halo counts i don't know if i read that
one taurus
uh no michael b
vanilla mac excellent thank you
ca jonte foster who said i've known
people in my life that have lost
the fight to this terrible disease this
may be small but it's a good cause
thanks for all you do again never
apologize for it being small
you know if you put any money towards
trying to help people
with cancer research there's there's no
there's no downside to the amount we're
very happy to have it
um jeff mcrae
i think you already donated jeff thanks
for joining he said lost my mom in
september 2014
to a bile duct cancer just 20 days after
her diagnosis that's
nuts happened to oh thinking about that
terrifies me um it happened too fast
people like you and funhouse help me get
through
very difficult times like birthday
christmas anniversaries thank you help
me laugh
thank you for sharing i don't know
how i would even recover if i lost my
mom in that way so you are
uh incredibly strong and i appreciate
you
thank you um all right
i think i've done everything here let's
go back to oh someone did say eat pie
that's pie right
that was a donation we ate the pie cross
that
off the list okay
um
yeah i'm gonna go back to the guild
that's what's up that's what's up that's
what's up
hello dub rumba how goes it oh just hot
dust hot
i've had saying this before but an
impossibly big work week
uh it's been exhausting
i'm i'm uh you know having to do another
stream
uh before i get to play fable
anniversary is ideal really
that's what you want after a big old
work week uh thank you casey
and anonymous we're at 3900
uh you guys get another fable bar real
soon that's all i'm saying you gotta
donate you gotta get to that 4k
i am also streaming on twitch yes mr
salvation i'm on twitch and youtube
hello
you must be the kid maze is always
talking about let's talk about imagine
what he sees in you
why is everyone so rude those maze knows
best british people
but where are my manners um yeah i'm
playing this on xbox one x
right now no time for autographs i'm
afraid i have to get to not hold glade
for an important
i'm absolutely not gonna play fable too
afternoon for a quest card all the best
ones
definitely not i'm sure the guild can
find you something just this one it's my
favorite the kitchen's nice
everyone's so [ __ ] mean
god damn you briar rose hey buddy
choose your path wisely hero an orchid
farm quest
for weights so we did specifically get
i have to go evil
and my handwriting looks so messy here
because i'm scribbling but
this is the list it does say good during
the trader quest but that's
after the orchid farm quest i have to go
evil for the orchid farm quest
thank you epsilon13 who said donating
for the bars hashtag [ __ ] cancer cancer
has taken a lot from me over the years
and i love seeing this
i respect it does the 15 bring us up not
quite not quite we need another 70
to get verse 3.
this pose is so bad
i love it okay
let's go have to go evil i don't feel
good about it
it's interesting that this guild exists
with like
no specific morality that they let you
do both it's very strange
uh we have to go attack orchid foam
[Music]
take quest and boast let's go i probably
should have leveled up first
i think i can boast and then go back and
level up though i can't
i'll
take no damage that's impossible don't
use weapons or any aggressive magic
no oh my god okay
in sure no bandits are killed i can try
that i'll probably fail at it but i can
try it i'm gonna do the naked one too
the other's just impossible so let's two
boasts
good stuff uh see if we can make some
money on myself there
first i'm gonna go back and i'm gonna
level up oh what's boasting
i'm glad you asked no dogs cam nile dog
scam
um you okay video game
buddy that's the slowest fade to black
i've ever seen
why was it that slow um boasting
is when you take a quest in the game
because of the way the economy system
works i guess or
just like the lore of the guild you can
basically just brag to people about how
you're gonna do it
and the more that you brag the more
renown you get
uh which means the more people know you
so if you're like i will do this
naked um because the townsfolk find it
interesting they're like you're sick and
then they'll be like you hear that guy
he's doing this [ __ ] naked
uh okay forces achievements that's
amount of damage
health i would like more health please
yeah physique
well speed is also really handy
is there anything else i can do with the
will though battle charge
i should have done battle charge instead
of
instead of what i actually did do
physical shield's good too
magic power level ones 500
i don't remember which ones i know i
love multi-strike
i love multi-strike i love lightning i
really like divine fury those are
probably the three that i like the most
actually
um so is it that i already bought battle
charge
i thought it was something else for some
reason
[Music]
i think i bought assassin rush
yeah i did okay it's fine
we're not going to buy any of these
right now
i will buy speed wait or is it no
guile's thievery isn't it yeah
my speed just for now
we'll save the rest i have to take my
clothes off
for this quest no hat no gloves
uh how do i unequip everything
i gotta take my pants off i gotta take
off all my clothes
no it's gonna be that way no gloves
no shirt we already have no shirt no
trousers that's such a weird way to do
an equipment system
no outfit great i'm naked
look at the little british little
british undies
okay that camera's awful let's not do
that all right let's go
let's go uh and when i'm not anywhere
near the chapel of school
nowhere near it oh my god we hit four
thousand i have to do more rap
thank you to dustin for twenty dollars
uh to
vanilla mac who said this is solely for
charity and has nothing to do with the
wrap i promise very nice
and adam l who said more rap for the win
okay it's fine you guys ready gonna do
more of this stupid [ __ ]
rap that i wrote in 2011. this is verse
3
which um
it's so terrible what i love
if there's anything that i love about
the fact that i wrote this
in 2011 again i would have been
18 when i wrote this would i have even
been 18 i might have been 17. uh what's
the [ __ ] math on that i don't know
um how old was i in 2011.
don't worry about it just pull out a
calculator i'm not i can't do math on
the planet
doesn't work that way it's 2020 2011.
it's nine years ago
i was 17 i wasn't even 18 yet i wrote
this when i was 17. this is what i was
doing as a 17 year old
and if there's anything that i love
about it it is the consistency in my
character
do i would i have known 17 year old me
that this is when i would be reading
this to people publicly
no uh but i love that
that i have really not changed all right
let's do the whole wrap
and then i'll give you verse three so
that's everything we've got so far okay
okay
i started out in oakville buying shocks
from a trader it was my sister's
birthday gonna give him to her later
[ __ ] dreamt that bandits would come and
raid us later she became one
that [ __ ] betrayed us i grew up in the
guild [ __ ] her slightly and whispered
but her daddy would be mad [ __ ] yeah
thunder i kissed her
finally graduated from the guild of the
zero [ __ ] up a big wasp now i'm
everybody's hero
don't judge me albie and i'm the [ __ ]
chicken chaser lock up your daughters
because you know that i could date her
suck my dick oh fail [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i'm
a [ __ ] slayer
come meet me in balkan and bower stone
[ __ ] don't be a stranger unless you're a
bandit you know i ain't a hater
that's the chorus first two protected
all could farm just to get with the
owner turns out she's a he but i still
got a boner took the traders through the
woods just to make a bit of cash
got distracted by the bordello and woke
up with a rash looking for the
archaeologist took me out to witchwood
but when i found the cockney [ __ ] he
told me i was no good
i killed the ballerina legs while
opening like demon doors i'm turning
sipple not whole glade folk
into massive [ __ ] first three
this is the new one you guys ready for
this for this [ __ ] fire
i got nominated for the witchwood arena
whisper [ __ ] suck dog yeah you should
have seen her
uh made enough gold to afford a master
katana but i still rock a villager
outfit
[ __ ] but i feel like i need to start
this one again because of my my own
status so let's just start again okay
i wasn't really horny one-eyed reaper i
was i was just trying to be
as vulgar as possible in my rap okay
just understand
what i was going for here uh i got
nominated for the witchwood arena
which would [ __ ] suck dog yeah you
should have seen her made enough gold to
afford a master katana but i still rock
a villager outfit [ __ ] spending dosh on
armor
my sister asked to meet me at the
haunted grey house gave me some [ __ ]
book that's when she
announced apparently my blood is royal
or some [ __ ] and jack of blades
kidnapped my mom because of it
this lost you light is so bad
[Music]
i do love um
made enough gold to afford a master
katana but i still rock a villager
outfit's box spending dash on armor
brilliant so the part of the rap that we
are up to in the game
is protected orchid farm just to get
with the owner turns out she she's a he
but i still got a boner except that i'm
not protecting it because the chat made
me not protect it we're actually going
to [ __ ] it up right now
um that's first three ladies and
gentlemen okay
you get verse four i'm gonna actually
only give you verse 4 because there are
only four verses when we hit 5000.
that's what i'm gonna do when we hit it
you finish the rap
but otherwise you don't get it you don't
get it so if you would like to donate
you should
all right but thank you guys for 4k
seriously
if you want depressing that wrap that's
what you got to do
that's what you got to do okay
i actually don't need to be naked to
start this quest at this point
prematurely naked ooh the title vendor
yeah you're sure to find something to
suit you
what should i do liberator druid
i will let the next person who donates
um again to the tiltify link not on
just youtube super chat uh pick
my name all right yeah
we can't afford avatar so no avatar
liberator druid ranger rune master hood
sabre pie monster chicken chase what
kind of a chicken chaser
i'm poor ass face we can't afford
next person who donates gets to choose
that's all i'm saying what would you
like me to be called
out of these 12 names except avatar
and chicken chaser which i devastatingly
cannot afford
i'm so close to being able to afford
that too three dollars off
wait i can't afford most of these that's
just grayed out
does that mean i can't afford that one
oh holy polar potable i've read this
wrong no i can afford all of them
this maybe is just unavailable right now
chicken chaser okay okay what are the
prices i
can't afford that i can't afford that
oh it's the red is confusing me because
i forgot the the economy system in this
game
so what it's saying with the red the
cost 650 is 600
um is that oh
uh it's more expensive than it normally
would be are any of these green
no they're all more expensive but i only
can't afford one of them
all right john already donated and it is
rune master let's do it
roon master done that's me
i am rune master and i am naked let's go
it's time oh you started chicken chaser
that makes sense
i uh i did not recall g'day lads
i'm not gonna [ __ ] with you just yet
it's not a good time to be doing both of
these quests
all right let's continue shall we
thank you anonymous for the ten dollars
we appreciate it
it's [ __ ] hot oh my god
it's the worst so you're going to be
doing some work down at orchard farm
pretty ripped i knew that was your two
calling tell you what
i'm going to pick up the other side of
this little question and teach you how
to choose better friends
all right [ __ ] i hope you've been
practicing you'll need all the
experience you can get to beat me i
don't feel like i should have to see you
oh look at his arms
nice dude good buns
good buds uh yeah i'm familiar with the
combat multiplier it's higher than the
moon
i'll help y'all i'm just punch these
[ __ ]
didn't even get my sword out just give
him a punch
that's the thing that i'm supposed to
dig but i can't yet because i don't have
a shovel
whoa thank you trent for the hundred
dollars
i knew it man it does do that i was
having this issue on pc the other day
where they weren't all mapped to the
correct face buttons and it was very
confusing to me
you goddamn right
um no why are you targeting the trainer
definitely todd
is this a threat is this a threat
i actually should be using my will i do
want to level that up faster
thanks lads thanks easy
easy
i like magic i've shared this stance on
multiple occasions on the internet
but if you have the option play as a
wizard in a video game
and you choose not to
i fundamentally don't understand you as
a person
i don't understand what you're about i
don't get it at all
and i think that you should think about
what you're doing with your life because
it doesn't make any sense
all right let's do it all good farm
thank you alan it's nice seeing so many
australians in the chat because i'm
streaming at like 2 a.m
you ready for a bit of violence i'm
ready for a bit of violence
just behind this gate mob's hair is
gonna blow it in
perfect we're after some crates the
farmer's got stored in his barn
don't know what's in them and i don't
much care excellent
we're just paid to do a job so don't go
asking questions
just lead us well mata x i do a warrior
like i usually do a
battle mage as it's called um
which is uh obviously a wizard crossed
with a warrior
but i just love spell casting you know
why would you not do it
you know what i'm saying i just don't
understand
um okay cover me while i get the correct
i think my other boasts were to not have
any
villagers die
so well
i hate that i'm doing this but you know
i'm doing it for the people or whatever
for honor no that game didn't come out
so much later
all right hero your will
energy is low well energy is low watch
that
all right yeah let's go boys let's let's
keep moving i know there's another wave
but
why are you following me aren't i
supposed to be following you
um here's your creek
i get the crate where are the other
guards
i know that they come at some point
lads this is totally not that easy right
right right
are there more of them
thank you george thank you so much
okay more of them have arrived
let's do it kill the rest of the gods
why couldn't two of you have held those
crates i don't understand
i can't let the ashes kill any of these
boys
did one of them die did you [ __ ] kill
one of them
i boasted that i wouldn't let any
archers die
better not be killing my arches boss no
not this guy here we go [ __ ] i said
arches when i meant to say
um bandits that's my i think that my
bandits are all okay
i'm not positive and i don't know why
you couldn't like what how much do these
crates weigh
why are they this hard to carry
who knows no one died excellent
thank you awesome joey i appreciate that
uh desa said i was curious any super
jazz cyphon 27.7
uh i wanted to know do you have a head
canon for your character already
like not even a little bit no i don't
know what i'll do i know what build i
want but head canon's probably not the
word that would apply to the way that i
play video games i don't think
um but i for sure want to do um a tech
build
i intend to play that game with as much
conversation as possible
i'm definitely going nomad too um
uh so yeah i guess i do know some of
those things but yeah i want to go more
more uh dialogue focus
more finagling my way out of quest focus
which is really why i love
cd projekt right i love the witcher 2.
lead the way um
obviously which three as well but the
witcher 2
is all about that [ __ ] for the amount of
choice you can have
it's what really got me when it comes to
approaching quests so that's how i'm
going to try to play soccer
i think we [ __ ] did it naked this was
not hard i somehow remember this being
harder
ah we got it
piece of cake piece of cake
thank you den doc carson kid i'm sorry i
butchered you so
you've learned some new moves yes well
you're not the only one okay
i hope you've learned how to flourish
the only way you're going to get close
to me
yeah i know how to flourish i've done it
to you i asked several times
but i could also just use my will on you
the whole time from a distance so
what are you gonna do about it you know
energy is low watch that
i am really just farming i'm sorry it's
probably not very interesting to watch
let's do a flourish honor
um but i'm just i'm just going for the
xps you know
oh should i miss that one
okay okay okay
because the more you use the will the
more real xp you get and i just want
cool spells as wizards ruled
damn you beat me again you do suck
i suppose this quest is yours then aloha
from hawaii oh thank you for the 150
donation thank you so much we're bound
to
thank you and thank you anonymous for
the five dollars what are we at now
we're at 4 360. let us go
thank you guys you've got the boxes
there's nothing else
just leave us
i got both my posts right
i did i did and whispers brooch
and the game says
let's go back to the guild for more
quests
uh if i plan to redux this playthrough
why bother grinding so i thought about
that right
it's because i can't help myself because
i still even now want cool spells
i'm also like it's not like i'm grinding
so i'm not fighting people that i
wouldn't already be fighting
like i am farming
in combat but yeah grinding's probably
not the right word to use
um because i'm not going out of my way
zodiac killer thank you you said i had
to donate after hearing those bars
iggy azalea who that's fair
uh i do need to stop streaming so i can
go to sleep
i'm gonna stop at at 2.
it's currently 1 38. if we don't hit
that 5k
you don't get the rest of the rap that's
all i'm saying that's all i'm saying
yeah that's how we got to make it work
thank you the duke strongly agree
absolutely love this game
it is very good okay
uh the trader escort one it says do good
there's someone donated for this so
we're doing it good
i did posting it again i shouldn't have
done it yet because i should have
got checked my xp should have checked my
xp
got plans tomorrow i was speaking about
this earlier in the stream ryan i plan
to sleep
i've had such a busy week where it's
been like 12 hour walk days consistently
um so my plan for tomorrow is to sleep
in and rest
and chill uh naked sure
that's not gonna happen yeah let's do
that wait wait they can they also like
doesn't one of them turn into a boundary
i can also so more people know who i
am thank you peace callus oh and
anonymous we just got
three hundred dollar donation from
anonymous and a fifty dollar donation
from
yippie cows that's how i'm assuming
that's it that means we're pretty we're
pretty close we're getting pretty close
to the rest of those traps until i'm
done i'm so upset
um okay trophies is what i wanted to do
whispers brooch use yes
just let everyone see it how do i do it
no is it that is it is it is it
is it that [ __ ] i don't remember how to
do it
how do i lift it uh what's the button x
a
a none of you are going to see it
oh i got him that's how you get more
famous
in this game by projecting your ego
let's go up to trophies and do the wasp
queen head also
yes hey it's pretty sick head
squeeze plus 30 renown okay
does this trader have anything good for
me what do you got boss i'm looking for
someone to take me to orchards i can do
that on the way i
pay you if you here's a deal just talk
to him yeah i can do that
oh [ __ ] stop okay i already go to
everybody
what's happened here did we just reach
the goal oh my god we did
oh my god that wouldn't happen out of
nowhere to
commandant 93 for 20 20. uh
lit l thomas 300 and anonymous 200
thank you guys so much we've hit 5 000
we did it on the stream that's crazy
thank you guys um that means i owe you
the final verse of the wrap um so let's
let's do it shall we let's go let's go
from the top
okay i started out on oakville
buying chocks from a trader it was my
sister's birthday gonna give them to her
later [ __ ] shrimp that bandits would
come and raid us
later she became one that [ __ ] betrayed
us i grew up in a guild [ __ ] a [ __ ]
named whisper but her daddy would be mad
[ __ ] ya thunder i kissed her
finally graduated from the guild of the
zero [ __ ] up a big wasp now i'm
everybody's hero
don't judge me albion i'm the [ __ ]
chicken chaser lock up your daughter
because you know that i could date her
suck my dick up [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i'm a
[ __ ] slayer
come meet me in bowie stone [ __ ] don't
be a stranger unless you're a bandit you
know i ain't a hater
protected orchid farm just to get with
the owner turns out she's a he but i
still got a boner
i wrote this when i was 17 and i was
drunk work about
uh got distracted by the buddha we got
it this is the quest we're up to
actually
took the traders through the woods just
to make a bit of cash got distracted by
the bordello and woke up with a rash
looking for the archaeologist took me
out to witchwood when i found the
cockney [ __ ] she told me i was no good
i killed the ballerina legs were opening
like demon doors i'm turning simple not
whole glade folk into massive [ __ ]
going great
[Laughter]
uh okay um for the record i'm not
embarrassed
jordan i'm not embarrassed by this okay
i had a good time it's fine
uh i got nominated for the witchwood
arena whisper [ __ ]
sucked dog yeah you should have seen her
made enough gold to afford a master
katana but i still rock a villager
outfit
outfit [ __ ] spending dash on armor my
sister asked to meet me at the haunted
gray house gave me some [ __ ] book that's
when she announced
apparently my blood is royal or some
[ __ ] jack of blades kidnapped a mom
because of it
this is where we're up to
um when to save mom from prison i had to
listen to some poetry i forgot about
that part of the game you do the gods is
like reading poetry
when same one from prison had to listen
to some poetry got [ __ ] tortured
because
jackie boy is jelly people used jelly in
2011
escaped any way to find out may's [ __ ]
me over it's no wonder the guildmaster's
never sober
that's a good line that that line is
good you don't send me a message right
now mate
um it's no wonder that girl's masters
never sober they [ __ ] up the guild for
the sword of aeons but i threw it in the
vortex at hammerlock with crayons that's
also
that's very nerdy that
is about the final choice of this game
they [ __ ] up the guilt with the sword
of aeons but i
threw it in a vortex at hammerlock with
crayons but jackie boy came back as a
[ __ ] dragon
i got enough on my plate with lady gray
[ __ ] nagging
i think this last paragraph is flawless
i surmise almost every major quest in
the game in this rap okay
that i wrote when i'm 17 and 2011. all
right okay
hey it's
it's i'm proud
uh thank you all so much for dating
dating
donating five thousand dollars for
pancreatic cancer
research pancreatic cancer research i
always say it the wrong way around
from anyone who doesn't know 8 survival
rate which is the lowest survival rate
of all cancers and they also get the
least funding
so even though we have reached our goal
of course i will leave this up so you
guys can still donate if you would like
to
to help uh pank1 summer 2020's campaign
um
like i said i'll finish the stream in 15
minutes yeah 15 minutes we can maybe get
through this quest
but you got my whole wrap you got my
whole wrap
so that's all you know that's all you
really wanted did i
say that i would do this quest naked
again
[Music]
i'm just gonna put my clothes back on
in case don't send me messages right now
i don't
[ __ ] off um
which is even better
or are they absolutely identical they
are
nope wrong one also wrong one it's gonna
be this way
uh i'm gonna wear just the apprentice
stuff because i think it looks the
nicest
ah you can just do it in outfit of
course you can get dummy
okay let's level up
shall we
i was a 17 year old drunk boy when i
wrote that rap absolutely yes
i'm always a 17 year old drunk boy deep
down
thank you for the five dollars anonymous
i appreciate that thank you
uh dancing apple said in a zombie
outbreak would you rather have a trained
gorilla with a mace and shield or an
armored unrideable rhino
i'm gonna go with the rideable rhino
because i feel like something that i can
use for transportation is probably more
helpful
i think for three dollars um i think i
can
notifications but i don't care like it's
not gonna
it's not a problem it's whatever um okay
i want to check my will spells
multi-strike i love a multi-string
so how much do i have still tons
actually
let's let's let's let's let's let's
you know you know toughness probably is
what i should probably do
and then if we only have 6 17
left i'm not gonna be able to get
anything
cool with me i am a wizard hero
i like it thank you for the 20 uh
anonymous
well i mean i wrote it when i was 17 the
drinking age in australia is 18 but
everyone in australia drinks from a very
young age so
it wasn't legal um
but i feel like it's pretty common for
australian teenagers to drink from like
15. which is probably
um because i started drinking
early you know that's probably why i
don't don't feel the need to
party much now don't recommend underage
drinking though
okay i think fairies oh yeah those dudes
are high
okay so i want to i do want to take that
dude or perform
yeah oh you'll take me to orchards use
your
when we if you want to try not to go
what do you guys want i think you want
the mushrooms
are you talking to me you know sound
waves can make your head spin into the
sun
if only i hadn't lost myself yeah so he
lost one in the guild but i need the i
think it's in the water
thank you anonymous for the 20 dollars
okay you're from the guild aren't you
you're from dub guild
don't you ma'am what a place i'm going
to
uh that's what i'm going to do that's my
response to you doing this because i'm
literally just going to them
you know what you're doing you [ __ ]
attention seeker
so let's just pull up my xbox app
and make it so you can literally never
talk to me
ever again or play video games with me
ever
let's go to his account
block no done mate good game is cool but
uh
enjoy your block okay i'm standing on
the stepping stones in that pool where
the door talks
yeah so they're telling me where the
mushrooms are but i don't remember where
exactly you find them
[Music]
is the great wood entrance the wrong way
should i have taken
i can just have him follow me later
actually
if i go to great wood this is where the
two traders are
yeah i didn't tell him to follow me
anyway so it's fine you can just do that
quest never
we can never do that question ooh i need
to scroll down sorry
yeah seeing the xbox 360 pop-ups is
pretty nostalgic
uh yeah i agreed to do this one good
right i did which we haven't even
stopped yeah that's fine
flourish oh i gotta keep using my wheels
keep using my well
and this we got that we got that multi
strike for a reason bro
let's roll wait are you still not all
dead
thank you
i must attack the trader i didn't want
to do that i didn't want to do that i
did almost do that
uh no uh uh obi-wan there are so many
people who have
a variance of obi-wan user names um
this is not
uh
fable4 this is fable anniversary
okay what are you doing on the ground
son in case that wasn't clear
multi-strike
why the sound design so weird there
okay let's go i probably should have
like ordered some food or some
some potions for this quest because this
quest can be pretty tough actually but
you guys maybe i'll be fine should be
all right
you will automatically acquire
experience associated with something
wait does twitch also say fable4 did i
[ __ ] up both the headlines
i mean twitch it like says openly what
game it is and it does say fable for
again an accident i only meant to say
i'm playing fable for charity
i'm not trying to say that i'm playing
fable fall it's my bad
there we go both titles have been
updated i didn't realize it on both
thank you andy you're not paying with
totally fine
thank you i appreciate it uh
okay let's go
i only have one silver key i can't there
are others nearby i just don't know
where they are
um but i think there's one even in this
area
if i look for it i think it might be up
i've missed like a significant amount of
them here we go
right you are alana right you are how
many channels do i read the chat on
right now it's just two
usually three i often stream to facebook
as well
um but today i chose not to for
really no reason no no actual reason
just just clicked on twitch and youtube
but they're all
in one chat it's not separated so it's
all in the same screen
i swear that like when i streamed this
on pc the other day i wasn't able to do
this
can combat rules this is just if they
that's what i want from fable 4
or i guess just the new fable it's not
even painful is
just map me spells like this man
kingdoms of amalor that
if you haven't played kings of kingdoms
of ammo
the remaster comes out start of
september
i loved that game it's a little bit
soulless because it's like the bones of
an mmo that that studio was planning to
make
really um but i really enjoyed the
combat in that game
you got chakrams yeah it's sick
i recommend it
the style of this is similar to kings of
mammalo that's kind of my point
no watch out trader i don't want to
attack you i'm just trying to attack
these wasps
i'm not trying to hit you man
[ __ ] just this guy come on
did i hit him try to get your combat
multiplier even higher
it does that wow thank you again sarah
yes i am familiar with uh with uh
finding the
the mushrooms i'm just not trying to do
it right now but thank you
respect room master i've married lady
graham some
obviously that's what my rap was saying
in some playthroughs and not in others
um i think it's less interesting if you
do marry her but it does give you access
to an area of the game you wouldn't
otherwise so
that's cool it's koat xbox exclusive i
can't imagine so it's an ea title
um oh or is it didn't it get solved by
someone else have set up a toll in this
region
be careful yeah i'm actually not sure it
was
ea and i think now it might be thc
nordic
i don't remember hmm
i don't think it's xbox exclusive by any
means being on game pass just means they
got a deal
it doesn't i don't think it's exclusive
i imagine it's on playstation
uh this is the part with the tall i well
i'm afraid
what would be the evil deed to do here
to get through war there isn't one
i can't do one i'll just kill everyone
is that the goal i'm gonna pass it off
as an evil
he's still alive
let me eat some pie real quick don't
mind me just eating pie
roll roll roll
the combat does not look very pretty at
the start of this game
because i don't have like any weapons
with cool almonds
and i don't have like multi
lightning which is way cooler
what
i wanna i wanna i wanna flourish i wanna
flourish
[ __ ] nice
yeah red meat love to see it
i'm gonna just look around this area
real quick wait maybe i should look
around this area real quick
you should play koa again that remaster
comes out
start of september
yeah i came rules like i don't tend to
do
a lot of this it's gonna be such a silly
thing to say while playing this
i don't tend to replay games a lot i i
play a lot of new stuff
um except for halo fable and banjo-tooie
which are my big three
specifically halo one um i replay all of
those
all the time
i guess i've also played final fantasy 9
a lot
that would be another one on the list um
dude but yeah i i love kingdom level
i really [ __ ] enjoyed it
the comment was just so good it it
kingdoms of amyloid to me felt like um
what a fable sequel should be in terms
of the
gameplay just without the humor but
it was like a good rpg team
okay open it what these bandits got
that funny goal yeah we like that
how about this one
i see augments [ __ ] rule in this game
i really do play the starter that's the
same virtually every time though which
is
um do this trade a quest
get the money go to bug fail by
katana equipped with
augment it's fine there's a strap
and the strat's worth doing
hello this
is the deal yes perform an act of great
evil in your sight
if i had any chicks that would do it do
i have any chicks to eat i
don't i'm sorry mate i can't
do any great evil in front of you
maybe some other time fam maybe some
other time but now is not the time
podca thank you
the best gaming woman on the planet ah
that's a silly thing to say there are so
many dope women who play games and i
don't want to be the best
i would like to just be one of a legion
of cool women
of which there are many but thank you um
and thank you for the x-cast yeah it's
stoked to be renewed so the show's gonna
keep going
what do i expect from a new fable
besides british humor that's pretty much
it
probably also pretty water thank you
reverend kiljoy
um i say that because of forza horizon
it is 2 a.m i should sleep thank you
casey i appreciate that
you're right what difficulty am i
playing on
that's so cute it's so cute that
that you asked that about this 12 year
old game
uh i gotta go to bed thank you guys so
much for helping me raise
five thousand dollars what do we end up
on here let's take a look shall we
we ended up at five thousand one hundred
and nineteen dollars phrase four
pancreatic cancer you guys can uh
obviously um continue to donate i'll
leave the link up
uh or i'll leave the campaign available
for probably another couple of days if
you would like to
here it is
no worries where the rap is concerned
you are most welcome dave my jam
um yeah for anyone who doesn't know
pancreatic cancer is what killed alan
rickman
steve jobs patrick swayze uh uh
obviously among with
many others um eight percent survival
rate is the lowest survival rate of
all cancers and it gets the least
funding somehow try to get your combat
multiplied even
shut up guildmaster
uh so yeah we we absolutely need help
trying to find a cure or
leading towards helping um so yeah this
is all going through pancan
you can donate and i will send all those
funds obviously directly
sorry it's pank1 network pancan is their
twitter handle um obviously all goes
directly to them so
thank you all so much uh full mixed rap
is not coming out you didn't raise
enough money fam i'm sorry
i'm sorry that's how it works
but i'm gonna keep uh keep playing this
game maybe i won't do this play through
but
this has been fun it's a great game i
will see you guys next time have a good
night or have a good day if you're on
the part of the world where you just
woke up
you